I'm currently finishing up a round of
deck reviews that will be out hopefully
sometime soon, and it made me think
about the different hurdles a deck can
face. Not necessarily the mechanical
weaknesses of a deck, but the
fundamental challenges that make a
possibly promising deck dead in the
water. So here, I'm going to go through
the four basic fail states of a deck,
the things that go so wrong they can
make it totally unworkable. All four of
these focus around the idea of a deck's
plan, so the natural starting point is
number one, your deck has no plan. This
is the first way a deck can fail, and it
simply means that the different elements
of the deck don't really come together
to form something that makes sense. It's
just a collection of cards. Now, I
should be clear here. It is absolutely
possible to make a deck that feels
cohesive and has a sense of direction
without specifically thinking of a plan.
Some commanders or mechanics or card
types just naturally lend themselves
well to a focused deck that can win
games. If you have a Jodah, the Unifier
deck, it's going to be able to create
massive boards of legendary creatures.
And if you have a landfall deck, it's
going to be able to generate a large
resource advantage while putting on some
pressure. However, there are other
mechanics where dedicating a deck to
them won't automatically create
something that makes sense. Let's say
you really like the death touch mechanic
and you want to build a deck around it.
There's Fynn, the Fangbearer, but you
want something that includes black as
well. So maybe you grab The Serpent
Society or Aveline de Grandpre. You add
some death touch supporting cards like
Hooded Blightfang and then drop in a
whole bunch of your favorite death touch
creatures. Great. But is this actually a
cohesive deck? It really depends on how
we filled out the deck. Death touch
creatures doesn't really gesture at a
particular gameplay timeline, late game
board state, or plan for winning. So a
death touch deck could have all sorts of
stuff in it. Maybe it's a lot of combat
damage to a player effects since people
don't want to block death touch
creatures. Maybe it's some counter
amplifiers to pair with Aveline's combat
damage effect or The Serpent Society's
ward. Maybe it's some snake synergies
since we've got a lot of those. And
maybe it's just piles upon piles of
death touch creatures we like. Depending
on what we filled out our deck with and
how dialed into it we were, the deck
might feel great, but it could also feel
like an uncoordinated mass of nothing.
This is where plan comes in. A deck
should really have an idea of roughly
what specific board state it would like
to create, when, and how that board
state will lead to victory. If instead
it just has a mood board of the most
aesthetic looking death touch creatures
or threshold creatures or some other
keyword creatures, it's going to run
into all sorts of problems. So, okay.
Let's say you figured things out. You
know who you are and what you want to be
doing. But what if that want isn't
turning into reality? This is where we
get to the second failure condition.
Number two, your deck fails to execute
its plan. This is where you know what
your deck wants to be doing, but it just
doesn't seem to consistently be
happening, at least not on a reasonable
timeline. To solve this, I need to
introduce a deck building concept that I
like to call widening your on-ramp.
Magic the Gathering is a game of chance,
and you can think about your game plan
as a big bucket that your deck is
randomly firing tennis balls at.
Sometimes you'll hit, and your desired
game plan will happen on your desired
timeline, while other times that won't
happen. Such is life. What this bucket
system represents, randomness, is
entirely unavoidable, but your deck
building choices control the size of the
bucket. Missing land drops will make up
some percentage of that miss territory,
a large percentage if your deck is
strongly enabled by a commander that
costs four or more mana. So, adding
lands to a deck that's low on them can
increase the size of that bucket.
Another thing that increases the size of
the bucket is trying to keep your deck's
payoffs lower costed and more broadly
useful. High cost amplifiers generally
increase your deck's peak power level,
but these typically don't help you jump
into your game plan. So, each one you
add also slightly narrows your deck's
on-ramp. All sorts of other cards also
might slightly narrow your deck's
on-ramp. And I've linked a video I made
a couple months ago that goes more into
that. Long story short, it can go a long
way if you make sure that a relatively
wide portion of your cards are helpful
early. The other big thing that can
widen your on-ramp is card draw. If your
deck isn't seeming to work, my first
suggestion will always be to add more
draw and filtering. A lot of times, this
will simply solve the problem because a
ton of EDH decks aren't running enough
draw, but that's not the only benefit.
Adding card draw helps even if that's
not the main problem with a deck because
it helps pick out what cards are working
and what cards are not. It's easy for a
card that doesn't work well to stay in
your deck if you only see it once every
four games, but bump that number up to
one in three or one in two, and suddenly
you're coming face-to-face with its
issues a lot more often. The same goes
for cards that feel really good in your
deck. If you've got something that's a
surprise powerhouse, drawing it in more
games can help that become clear, and
you can modulate your deck to play into
its strengths accordingly. As a final
note here, sometimes the decks you play
against might just be faster than your
desired game plan can reasonably be. You
can optimize as much as you like, but
some ideas just aren't suited for a
particular caliber of game plan due to a
limited pool of cards or some inherent
weaknesses. I might make a video about
those at some point, but for now, I'm
going to move past them and assume that
you've succeeded in assembling a deck
that has a plan and is able to execute
it. What could go wrong from there?
Number three, your plan sucks for other
people. Commander is a social format.
You're playing a game with three other
people, and you're generally there to
have a fun time. So, what happens if you
pull up with your beautiful new creation
and it just bumps the table right out? I
wish this was an area where I could just
tell you what's A-OK and what's
off-limits, but really it's kind of
complicated, and there are two main
variables at play here. Variable one is
who you're playing with. Some playgroups
are going to be a lot more accepting of
spicy decks than others. And generally,
people who've played the game longer
will be more on the accepting side. It
might strike some people as weird that a
large group of players are okay with
lockout control and land destruction and
the like, but it makes more sense when
we think about it in terms of type one
fun versus type two fun. Type one fun is
doing stuff that feels good in the
moment, whereas type two fun is about
doing stuff that kind of sucks in the
moment, but is rewarding later.
Playing a fiddly midrange pile is type
one fun, whereas defeating an especially
nasty opposing deck or navigating a
perilous situation falls more into the
realm of type two fun.
This might sound like I'm grouping
people into type one players and type
two players, and there will be people
who lean toward one or the other, but
ultimately almost all players are going
to enjoy a mixture of these two things
in varying amounts. You'll find the
dino-playingest of Timmys getting jazzed
at the sight of some degenerate Xur the
Enchanter nonsense, and on the other
hand, you'll get an old-school player
who doesn't particularly want to play
against your Kefka deck today. And
that's the important thing here. Whether
or not your opponents want to play
against a deck isn't necessarily an
all-or-nothing question. They might be
fine playing against a spicy deck once
in a while, but making a deck that's
more irritating to play against might
mean less times when your opponents want
to play against it. And if your goal is
to make an everyday default sort of
deck, that could easily constitute a
failure. The second variable here is
your own willingness to subject your
opponents to things. If you know that
you're somebody who will struggle to
enjoy playing your deck if your
opponents react negatively to things you
do, you'll want to avoid some of the
video tools out there. On the other
hand, if you don't care one bit about
your opponents having fun, you'll have a
much wider range of stuff you can do.
Whether or not that's a good thing is
another question, but it is a true
statement. Personally, I'm somewhere in
the middle. I like when my opponents are
having fun, but I also tend to play
decks that present a very specific type
of problem to my opponents, and that
isn't always well received in the
moment. Getting challenged is
challenging. Sometimes we end up driving
through the outskirts of Frowntown, but
I at least try not to stick people in
the same sort of difficult situation for
too long. It is a balance, but it's what
I need to do to play the decks I like to
play in a social format. So, okay. Let's
say your deck has a plan, is able to
accomplish that plan, and you can make
peace with whatever the opposing
reaction to that plan is.
What else could possibly go wrong?
Number four, your plan sucks for you.
Sometimes a deck just doesn't live up to
our hopes for it. You imagine a
particular play pattern, a particular
sequence of actions, or a particular
game state, but upon attaining that, you
realize that it just isn't that fun for
you. This is a very common issue, and to
me, it's just a part of figuring out
what it is that you enjoy within the
Commander format. Some people enjoy
finding the weirdest combos out there,
while others do not. Some people like
playing an extremely complicated pile of
nonsense where there's always another
possible line, and to other people, that
sounds like hell. Some people like
making a massive board full of beasts,
and other people fall asleep playing
that sort of deck. You can take guesses
as to what you will or won't like, but
you won't know for sure until you've
tried it out. And, like the last failure
condition, this one isn't necessarily
all or nothing. You might put together a
deck that you really like playing
sometimes, but that simply can't be your
bread and butter. That is a failure if
you were looking to build a deck you can
play with a lot, but it might not be so
bad if you're just looking for variety.
It's also not a crime to get tired of a
deck eventually. If you build a deck
that executes a very cool, very specific
game plan, you might get a kick out of
playing it for the first half dozen
times, but it might start to lose its
luster after that. If you poured a ton
of money into buying it in paper and
bling it out, that's going to sting a
bit. However, a deck like that
eventually falling by the wayside
doesn't take away from it being fun in
those first handful of games. Doesn't
negate your past enjoyment. The key here
is expectations. If you're building a
deck, try to have an idea of how often
you expect to play it and how long you
expect it to stay fresh. No deck is a
failure if you have yourself in the
right mindset for it, and that mindset
is something you can build with
experience.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to
Architect for supporting the channel.
Architect's folder system lets me
comfortably group my sometimes decks
separately from my always decks, which
feels correct to me for some reason.
Well, I guess I have my Malfegor deck in
the main deck folder, but what can you
say? A guy's got his favorites. A link
to my decks is down in the description.
I'd also like to thank Dragon Shield for
their support of the channel and for
keeping my decks secure.
I'd love to resleeve my Radha deck at
some point, but I made a pact that I'd
wait until a sleeve broke, and so far
those peach dual mats are surviving the
thousands of shuffles I put them through
just fine. You can grab yourself your
own set of dual mats at the affiliate
link in the description, and you can use
code Salubrious for 5% off. Doing so
supports the channel and lets me keep
doing what I do. Also supporting the
channel are my lovely patrons and
YouTube members, some of whom are on
screen now. If you want to join this
esteemed group of individuals, you can
join as a YouTube member or follow the
link to my Patreon down in the
description.